もう
悲鳴が
響き渡ってますねこんにちははじめしゃ
ちょーです
久しぶりにやってまいりました戦慄迷宮
です
今日も
綺麗な建物ですね最高のデザインですよ今
開演中でたくさんのお客様が戦慄迷宮に
入ってもうなぜか怖い思いしてますもう
本当に怖いんですけども僕は行き過ぎて
普通の旋律免許はいけますよと多分結構
トップレベルで言ってるよね
メーカーなんですよ大丈夫
耳鳴りしてる俺だけ
良かった呪われたと思った戦慄迷宮かなり
の回数行っててだいぶ慣れてるので正直
あの中の作りとか小物の場所とかどこのお
風呂場の浴槽に何がいるかとかこの
オフィスにはどこに何があるかこの
ビーカーの中には何が入ってるか
ここで出てきますとかここはランダムで
いるかいないか決まりますとかもう
いろんなことわかってるんですよ僕
前前ハウスこんなもう愛してやまない戦慄
迷宮今日は
閉園後にお客さんが一人もいない働いてる
人もスタッフも誰もいません何もいない
旋律迷宮で朝までいたら何か起こるのか
やってみたいと思います夜は誰もいません
もんねセキュリティの方もいらっしゃら
ないです
ゼロなんですよこれで物音がなったら本当
に何かあるし色んな人が怖い思いして
いろんな思いして入っていくと思うんです
よ結構そういう気がたまってる場所だと
思うしさっき
探しだと聞いたんですけど白い女の霊が
いるとかいないとかいう噂も聞いたので
もうそろそろ終わりの音楽鳴ってますね
永遠の時間が近づいて参ってましたが
ちょっとねどうなるか止まってみたいと
思いますでは閉園までしばしお待ちを
[音楽]
はいというわけで
閉園しました
富士急ハイランドにはもうお客さんがい
ないかなぐらいの時間です戦慄
迷宮ももうお客さんいませんゼロですお
[拍手]
疲れ様
の作業終わったぐらいなのかなとりあえず
でその電気がついてたりとかそのオープン
してる時の様子1回見て回りましょうか
行きます
こういう感じですよ普段は
いやー怖いけどねオープン時でもオープン
時が怖いよね
もうこういうのね
怖いですよ
こういう感じですね戦慄迷宮見慣れた景色
なんじゃないですか
さらに見慣れてる景色から
光全部消えるわけでしょ
怖えよマジで
ここね座って待つところね
ここで待ってお話とか聞いてから戦慄迷宮
に行くというここまだ入り口ですね
はいというわけでそろそろ多分電源落ち
そうだね
助かるじゃんなくなるって事今から
怖いよ
真っ暗の中生活するってこと
にしよう
[音楽]
ぜ消えた
やばい
はいというわけで全ての電源が落ちました
ね照明もないです逆に言うとここから物音
すると早速
閉園後の戦慄迷宮行きたいと思います今ゴ
ンって言わんかった
気のせいでやってくれよマジで
じゃあ行きますね
誰かいるでしょさすがに
誰がいます
いや行ってくんないとマジで困るんだけど
ねぇ俺も動けないんだけどマジで
えどうするどうするどうするね
俺今日ここで止まるんでしょ
ばっかじゃないの今のドン何
言ったよね
誰かいます
スタッフさんいたら教えてください
お願いします
いないわ
ガツ丼だね
失礼します
待って本当に怖いんだけど
こういう緊急用の照明みたいなのが一応
ついてるのね
慣れて俺これ生きる気しないんだけど先に
ただ戦慄迷宮みたいに脅かしてくる
ギミックがなくなったからそこは安心して
いい
それが怖いんだけどね
行くよ今聞こえたなんか勝ってた
失礼します
でもどんどん行くよ
ここだけスタート
ここだよね行きます
基本的に音はないはずなのよ基本的にと
いうか会っちゃダメなんだけどね
[音楽]
ここいつもいるところねこれ
いつもお化けいるところです
音楽ないの結構でかいな
いつもさその
環境音とかで
怖いじゃん
あれこれどこだ
俺たち間違えた
[音楽]
ねちょっと
意外とわかんないです
[音楽]
こいつ下げちゃって
あでもぽいこっちだ多分
ほら
2年後の俺と剣好き俺
らこんなとこにいるんですか
[音楽]
あれこんなとこ通ったっけ
でもさ普通に来たよね
書いてあった道を
[拍手]
え迷っちゃってる
いや知らない知らないこんな部屋見て
めちゃくちゃ怖いよでも
これ
[音楽]
まずいな戻ろうかマジで迷っちゃった
こんな秒殺で迷うことある
助かりました
はいスタッフさんに助けていただいて
元のルートに戻ってくれましたいや迷うね
これ普通に
さあ
頼むよこれももう大人にならないとだもん
ね
これとかいつもすごいガスの音するのよ
全部が止まっている
全部が止まっているので音は鳴らないはず
なのよ
[音楽]
大丈夫
何もないはずだ何もねえよな
いやマジでここからは音が鳴ったら
おかしいからね
こんにちは
階段です
2回行きました
空調とかなってるのね音は
失礼しますここね
この
洋室チェックなうわもう人の影がマジで
怖い
見て
見えるかなこういうテレビは生きてるんだ
勘弁してよ
国怖いけどなこっちからすると
ついきます
うわぁ怖い
怖いよ
大丈夫何も出てこないもうなれる
ぞ何も出てこない
聞こえた俺だけ
ほらほら今ほら
きしみ音ということで解決しましょうか
絶対ただ死んでるだけ大丈夫大丈夫
言い訳できれば大丈夫その音に対して
あと多分さあエアコンとかが止まったから
さ空気が暑いのよ
ちょっとどよっとしてる感じがまたマジで
許してって感じ足
こういう
廊下が一番怖いんですよ
[音楽]
落としたら結構俺無理よ
見て
これ
髪の毛
[音楽]
怖いよね
これで次階段下降ります
そうだねまず
止まる止まるというか朝までいるっていう
事だから結構そのずっと入れる場所を探さ
ないとね
どこにいようかな
やばいよ
無理だよ
一人ってこと
どうしてくるんだようわぁ怖いよ
いやーお邪魔しますじゃあとりあえずさ俺
がその泊まる場所だけ
泊まる場所決めれるまではついてきて
くれる
それ以降俺との
おかしいよもう
失礼します
うわぁやばい
こういうゾーンね
これですよ
ねこの戦慄迷宮の中のディティール見る
ことないですから
本当に
人の顔とか初めて知ったもん
俺いろいろあるんだな見ないもんね普通ね
この階段も普段なら言うんですけど多分
名前はずよねだったらどうしよう
行きますなんないよね
大丈夫だここでなんなかったらなんない
ポイントがあるんだよなる瞬間の
どこに泊まろうかなぁ
失礼します
エアコンは止まってるけど空調はついて
そうな気がする
いやここに水回り系怖いよね
結構やなんですよね
まだ水回り手続きますこれここらへん
もう嫌なんだよ
お疲れ様です
待ってましたよ
帰ります
企画出た時にさ
なんとテレビでも同じような企画やって
まして
止まってたんですよテレビ番組でもガン株
でしちゃっててちょっと本当にパクリとか
じゃないよ証拠ないかなテレビのオンエア
前にこの話出てた企画でかぶってんですよ
やることが
というわけで帰ります
明らかに俺たちが違うのはね出るのよこの
2人いると間違いない心霊屋敷とか音
すごかったからちょっとね今このまさに
旬の呪われている2人であれば何か起きる
んじゃないかということであと承認も
欲しいのよ一人で泊まっててさ俺が
メラメラこんなことあったって言ってもさ
信じらんないじゃん
編集でさ音が立つとかなんか
そんなことしませんから本当に証人として
ちょっといてほしいのと
[音楽]
怖いと
ここ1人はね
やるよ1人でも止まりますけどカメラマン
としてちょっと彼も一緒に見てもらいたい
と思いますわかりますよろしくお願いし
ますお願いします
頼んだ頼んだはい
頑張ってあれあれダメですじゃあ
とりあえず寝床を探すか3人になったら
心強いわあれ
お
疲れ様です
[音楽]
驚かされないってことよね
こんなにイージーなことないよもうただ
なった時は終わりですけどどこをベースに
するかだな
なんかジャリジャリするね
手術
室です
手術うまくいくといいですね
ここ音鳴らないて分かったらもう全然
いけるあー
怖いちょっと怖いちょっと怖い
ちょっと怖い痛そううまくいきますように
ファイト
さあ結構深いとこまで来ましたよ
こっちね
[音楽]
疲れた
まずまず長いですよねこの
階段とかめちゃくちゃあるのよ
[音楽]
ビスコのパッケージの候補だった男の子
でした
こういうルートはやっぱ長い色が怖いよね
[音楽]
失礼します
なんかカチカチ音なってんだよなさっき
からうわ
ぁやばいですよもう
長いしちょっと
寒いしめっちゃ刺されとるやんけなんか
寄った勢いで間違って黒ひげ危機一髪自分
でやってみたいたまにこっち行かされる
ルートもあるんだよね
ただ今はこっちですね入っちゃうタイプか
ドクターマリオ
失礼しますここはカルデ保管庫
あー怖いこういうターンにも隠れてますね
たまに
人じゃないことを願う
2年室です
こういうのって落ちたりしたらもうその時
は終わりです
乳幼児
いるね
子供たちがいますね後ろの手形とかマジで
怖い
新生実質ですね
やべえここ
ちなみに
この戦慄迷宮の噂レベルの話ですよ本当か
どうかとかは知らないです噂ですけど
この部屋が一番出るらしいです
なんか女の人を見たとか
あとこういうちっちゃい子供のお人形とか
例えば宿りやすいらしくて話を聞く限りで
は一番スポットということで今日はここに
泊まりたいと思います
どうせならね
ここに泊まりたい
ほらバブー
こういうね人の形してるとねやっぱ宿っ
ちゃうらしいですよ
あとその心霊スポットよりやばいのがさ
めっちゃ人来るじゃんなんか俺握手会とか
でも聞いたことあるんだけどやっぱ強い
気持ちを持って人が来る場所ってなんか
そういうの集まりやすいらしくてワン
チャンに心霊スポットよりたくさんの人が
怖いっていう気持ちを持ってここに来る
から気が集まりやすい場所にもなりやすい
らしくて
知らんけど僕そういうの全く信じない
タイプなんであれですけどそれなりに人の
感情がこう
好まれたくさんいる動いてるわけだから
まあ心霊スポットなのかパワースポットな
のかわかんないけどちょっと怖いねここら
辺で
ちょっと朝まで過ごしたいと思います
[音楽]
ここでは間違いないいや
怖い
はい皆さん聞いてください彼ですねさっき
まですっごい体調悪くなって車で寝て動け
なくなってました大丈夫今はなんとか回復
したんですけどさっきは本当にやばかった
です
[音楽]
だんだん体調悪くなったんで
ワンちゃん
疲れました
というわけで今です23時でもうすぐ
ちょっとね横になろうかなっていう時間で
あるんですけどどうせだったらねちょっと
回ってみようぜもうすぐ日付変わるんです
けど
24時のさこういう場所とかもすごい
じゃん
ちょっと回ってみましょう俺たちが行った
ところさ
結構空調の音大きいじゃん
別れなそうなんだよね
[音楽]
こういう時に物音とか人の声をすると
やばい
怖い
これ戻れるのかなそして
このまま
迷宮入り
どこかで見たドッキリなんですね
嫌です
[音楽]
今なんかなったよね
ここら辺で寝るのもありや
な
寝やすそう
[音楽]
初めてです
富士急始めてきましたここで普通だったら
脅かしてくるからね
まあまだ
脅かしてこないってわかるのがありがたい
ですけど逆に
落としたら
当然やばいです全く俺と同じこと言ってる
こんなとこで施されたら
ここで寝る今日
ここで見るか
あれ来てない
こんな
寒いの動いたらマジでやばい
ほらやばい
[音楽]
本当だ
寒い
これエレベーター
今もう動かないんじゃないか
多分動かないね
普通に死にそう
[音楽]
で
待ってやばい
やばいいなくなったか
[音楽]
はいというわけでこの部屋で寝ようと思っ
たんですけどちょっとね空調の音とかが
結構大きいのでもうちょっと静かな場所に
移動したいと思いますそこちょっと横に
なりましょうか
空調の音がうるさいかな
ここにしようかなぁ
ここも音がすごい
鳥肌やばい
こことかも結構やばいよねこういう
階段とかこの
じゃあちょっとこの階段付近で
止まってみるか
一応ね横になれるようにボストン
準備しましたちょっと
頑張っておくと持ってきますこれも一苦労
だな
持ってきました
なんかちょっと
距離あるの逆に怖いんですけど
上の方でちょっと横になってみます
どうする音したら寝てる時に
ね
あと上やばい
上やばいよ上はねもうこっちから来るん
じゃないかって恐怖
こっちとここはあんた本当にマジでやばい
テレビも怖いし
で下にはもっとこれ一番
[音楽]
怖いよ
隣に来てほしい
行きたいです
[音楽]
モンストしてていいお願いします
寒くないのに寒い
[音楽]
操作
切りです
[音楽]
足引っ張られたらどうしよう
間違えました
[音楽]
大丈夫か
ちょっと前に
嘘でしょ
[音楽]
聞こえたね
やばい
怖い
こんな怖いんだ
止まったなんか
わかんなかった
気にしすぎか
やばいからだ
まいっか
おやすみ
起きてる
はい
[音楽]
今丑三つ時深夜の2時ですちょっと
せっかくなので場所移動して寝てみたいと
思います
移動
こことかどうすか
怖いな
なんか
何が光ってるんだろう
[音楽]
何かが反応
して
監視カメラ
次はこの廊下で寝てみようと思います
おそらくこのまま朝を迎えることになり
そうですねでは
いいね荷物全部こっち置いて
で
びっくりしたそこにね
いいね荷物全部こっち置いて
[音楽]
なかったですよ
閉まってると思う
やばいわ
これやばいです
しまってたんですよずっと
奥まで
ここ空いてて今見たら
人形かな
なかったよね
気づくよねこうやって置いてたら
まあいっか
一生安心できない場所が広い
足音聞こえた気がしています
はいベッド持ってきます
ねぇ待って
間違えた
ね
言うわけないでしょ
待ってこれがキモい
ここで止まるここのが怖いよね
なんかもっと怖そうな場所だったんで奥に
します
動いてね
久々に男の手握ったわ
[音楽]
さっき音出てたよ
ただいま
[音楽]
寝ます明るいな照明
暗くしてナイトモードで寝かせてください
ちょっとマジで寝
ますおやすみなさい
[音楽]
[拍手]
おはよう
大丈夫か朝になりましたおはようござい
ますはいまあ朝なんですけどお化け屋敷な
ので真っ暗ですねひとまずこれで
撤退したいと思います
[音楽]
おい帰ろうぜ帰ろう今完全にガタン
聞こえた
ここでね
[音楽]
なんだ今の音最後の
ナイトモード解除
[音楽]
出ることができました
はいというわけで無事に先日迷宮出ること
ができました結構その寝てた時間があった
ので音が何があったかとかはわかんなかっ
たですけど
何個かは普通にねえーそんな音するみたい
なねさっき最後とかね結構ガタンと言った
もんねなんか
あるんですかね
[音楽]